for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy so
in this video I want to talk about the
different types of chemical formulas
that you will likely come across in your
studying of chemistry okay so when it
comes to a chemical formulas the first
thing we should do is define them okay
so a chemical formula is basically
combination of element symbols and
numerical subscripts that denotes the
type of atoms and how many make up the
smallest unit of that substance whether
it's a molecule or a formula unit for
example I've got four examples here
first one is h2o which is water a lot of
people know that specifically we've got
the element symbol for hydrogen which is
that H and a subscript to write the
numerical subscript 2 that follows it
indicating that there are two hydrogen's
in addition we've got the oxygen oxygen
is represented by the elemental simple
oh and there's no subscript which
basically implies that the subscript
would be one okay so what really going
on there is we have that's telling us
that we have two hydrogen's and one
oxygen by two hydrogen atoms and one
oxygen atom for every one molecule of
water and ice a molecule because these
are both nonmetals hydrogen and oxygen
are non metal that are combined and
that's a covalent compound okay next up
here LF three so that's aluminum there's
a LZ symbol for aluminum and there's no
subscript with some plies one aluminum
and we've got f3 so that's fluorine
followed by three those three fluorines
and so we've got one aluminum for every
three fluorines right but this is
specifically an ionic compound because
it's a metal and a nonmetal aluminum is
a metal so there's one aluminum ion for
every three fluoride ions okay and so in
every one formula unit of a LF three
which is not a molecule right it's a
formula unit
okay next up MGO another ionic compound
is got metal and a nonmetal mg is
magnesium so there's one magnesium ion
for everyone oxygen ion in a formula
unit of the compound that is mg o ok
over here the last example co2 one
carbon two oxygens in one molecule of
carbon dioxide one carbon and two oxygen
atoms in one molecule of carbon dioxide
okay so now there's three different
types of chemical formulas there are
molecular formulas empirical formulas
and structural formulas so what does
each one tell us let's start with the
molecular formula the molecular formula
shows the actual number of component
atoms of each element in a compound ok
so let me just use the best way to
explain this with is with an example and
I'm going to use the example of glucose
for all three of these types of formulas
so example is glucose glucose is a sugar
a monosaccharide you don't need to don't
want a sec all right means at least not
yet but if you do awesome so glucose I
want the molecular formula of glucose
that shows me the actual number of
component atoms of each element in the
compound so in one molecule of glucose I
have six carbons 12 hydrogen's and six
oxygens in one molecule glucose that
that's what i have right and so this is
the molecular formula of glucose right
here ok that's the molecular formula
next up empirical formula the empirical
formula shows the lowest whole number
ratio of atoms in a compound ok and it's
actually derived from the masses of the
component elements in that compound and
we're not really talking about too many
details of that right now we're gonna
talk about the definition but that's
something we'll talk about more we talk
about stoichiometry anyway so if it
the lowest whole number ratio of atoms
then what would the empirical formula
for glucose be well I notice here that
I've got six carbons for every 12
hydrogen's for every six oxygens so
there's a six to 12 to six ratio so I
think about 6 to 12 to six I notice that
the greatest common factor of all of
them is six right so i could divide them
all by six and i'll get a one to two to
one ratio and so the empirical formula
would be C 1 H 2 O one right so CH 20
okay that would be the empirical formula
for glucose right I just divided each of
those numbers by six okay so that tells
me the lowest whole number ratio of
Adam's right what about the structural
formula the structural formula shows the
atoms and the bonds between them so it
kind of shows you the structure the
actual structure of the molecule okay so
it's going to so if I know the molecular
formula for glucose is c6h12o6 that
means if i draw the structure I should
have six carbons 12 hydrogen's six
oxygens so let's reveal what that looks
like review all these atoms here is part
of glucose okay so let's just check it
out so this is the actual structure of
glucose at least when it's in it's a
linear form so i should have six carbons
12 hydrogen's and six oxygens let's just
verify that so let's cut the carbons
first circle lemon yellow so we've got
one two three four five six carbons ok
cool that checks out we've got six
carbons about hydrogen's we should have
12 so there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
hydrogen's that checks out to so last
thing is six oxygens we've got one two
three four five six oxygens that checks
out to
okay so that's the actual structure of
glucose now I kinda want to erase all
the circles i just made just to indicate
that or just to make it less messy i'll
just sort of count the atoms but also
those are all the atoms but the bonds
between them are important as well right
there's there is this bond here
connecting those two atoms there's a
double bond there there's a there's a
bond here as a bond here all these
different bonds between these atoms
that's what the structural formula shows
you in addition to the atoms themselves
so do the atoms and how they're
connected and that's specifically for
glucose anyway I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying